let's go
next to
jake from chicago jake from chicago
you're on the air
jake from chicago you were on the air
fellow can you hear me david yes i can
hey david i'm a long time listener i'm
currently a student at the university of
alabama and one recent trend among these
southern college football games has been
the f joe biden chance hearing these
lunatics completely make ironic keep
politics out of sports and then feel the
need to disrupt the environment of the
game how do we approach dealing with
these kinds of people
uh well approach in what sense you mean
what should be done at the game when the
chant breaks out or more generally just
in general speaking like how can we just
like
change it so that these people aren't
completely hypocritical with what they
say i'm not aware of any way to the
hypocrisy has actually we've been
covering the hypocrisy for more than a
decade on the show and the hypocrisy has
only gotten worse and worse my body my
choice
uh when it comes to
the vaccine but not when it comes to
abortion
no debt and deficit or bad except when
it's a republican president don't
regulate businesses except when they
want to require vaccinations so i think
it's a lost cause on the hypocrisy i
think we've just got to figure out a way
to not be annoyed with them um and
i've been reading about the chants at
the football games it's like wow big
surprise a football audience in the
south of the united states doesn't look
like joe biden it's got to me it's kind
of like it's not really big news you
know
yeah i remember when two years ago when
trump came to the alabama versus lsu
game i've never heard a louder stadium
in my life it was
just crazy these people going absolutely
nuts for this man yep well that is the
south and they uh tend to vote
republican so not really surprising but
you know quite frankly i'd be avoiding
large sporting events at this point in
time and then i i'm both skipping the
coved risk as well as the by anti-biden
chance
yeah that's fair i i enjoy going to
games but i'm also messed up at the game
so i'm trying everything i can to
mitigate but i completely understand
about knoxville that's interesting how
how many other are are people tending to
wear masks it's not no nobody nobody has
masks on there our school does have a
mask mandate yeah but in outdoor areas
people don't really follow it as much
all right yeah and outdoor it is less uh
less less important i would agree all
right well stay safe down there jake
well thank you thank you
there is jake let's take a quick break
if you're holding to talk to me don't
hang up
uh because we're going right back to the
phones momentarily